Speaker 2: Let's get back to discord David
Pakman dot com slash discord. We are taking
calls for the week and seeing what's on people's
minds. Let's go. Why don't we go next to Derek
from Orange County? Derek, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Hi, David. I had a quick question about
generally how you see the market GOP and feel
free to reframe the question if it's a little
too convoluted for you. I just wanted to ask how
you see this current iteration of the MAGA GOP. Do
you see it as a logical conclusion of the modern
GOP as well as other leaving behind folks like
Romney, Liz Cheney? Or were there politics like a
necessary conclusion to our logical conclusion to
what we're seeing now with the current MAGA GOP?
Speaker 2: Listen, I don't know about logical
conclusion, but there is a continuum and I talked
about this earlier in the week where this all go.
The modern MAGA GOP is the conclusion. Let's
wait on logical. But it's the conclusion to.
Civil rights era starts upsetting 1950s
conservatives who feel as though minorities
are starting to get too many rights and
too entitled or whatever leads to Reagan
and anti welfare sentiment and some kind
of like mean politics leads to the Gingrich
takeover as Speaker of the House in
94 and radicalization of the party.
Clinton derangement syndrome during
the Ken Starr Lewinsky investigation.
Dum dum George W Bush that ushered in kind of
just a lot of non thinking people into the party.
Obama Which coalesced a bunch of racists into the
party and conspiracy theorists. And then Trump was
sort of like the final layer so far, like there
will be more layers as time goes forward. So
whether it's logical, I don't know. But it's been
a steady 50 year decline. So in that sense, it's
not completely unpredictable, I guess I would say.
Speaker 4: Yeah. I mean, I'm pretty kind of new to
in terms of like paying attention to politics. I
would say that ever since, I guess. TRUMP But I
feel like for some reason the sentiment of, like,
not really accepting the election results doesn't
feel too new to me, but it's definitely a lot
more prevalent in this current political climate
right now. I don't know if you agree with that.
Speaker 2: I agree with that. I completely agree
with that. Yeah. It's become you know, it's the
overt nature and brazen nature of if we when it
was fair, but if we lost, it was rigged.
That is that that feels new and different.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
Yeah. Well, thank you so much for
taking my call. I really appreciate you
summarizing that very clearly for me.
Speaker 2: I appreciate the opportunity to
do so very much. Thank you for the call.